is here okay there's football and
there's Oktoberfest and Ellis Island is
the place to be for both events okay
something for everybody the general
manager Christina Ellis is here with all
the details I have to ask you just just
I figured this out in my head Ellis
any relation family business hey that's
so cool all right now to introduce
anyone who's never been to Ellis Island
what they can do there yeah so Alex
silent just to block off the strip
karaoke make all of our own beer super
fun place great Casino low limits it's
just a great place for it to hang out
for locals or tourists I love it and
we're combining for fall football and
October Fest Beer Fest so let's talk
football first what do you have planned
absolutely so we have a beer garden on
our site the front yard so inside the
front yard we have 18 foot big screen 25
we're seeing it right now
all over property great food uh great
drink packages beer and wine packages
all the way up to Premium Bar awesome
sit watch all the games and enjoy so
cool and I'm looking at that pretzel but
we have one right here what makes your
pretzel so special besides the fact that
they are huge well yeah they're huge and
we're serving with beer or beer cheese
made with our Ellis Island beer oh okay
that's fine I'll have to taste that in a
minute now let's talk about Oktoberfest
you know just explain what that means to
people into you at Ellis Island amazing
pretzel Segway because that's a very
important part of our October very very
important so this Saturday the 24th
we're having our Oktoberfest event so
we'll have live music steinholding
contest pretz leading contest costume
contests and then your ticket gets you
all the Ellis Island beer you can drink
okay appetizer and entree of Oktoberfest
bites now let's talk about this beer
because I've heard it is is special it's
great it's great we Brew it all at Ellis
Island it's you know been a brewery one
of the largest breweries here in Nevada
we have six different beers that will be
included in our Oktoberfest event and
our Oktoberfest beer which is now
pouring ah okay okay and then you
mentioned costumes yes so let's explain
to people what you know what costumes
would win this event yeah so
oktoberfestyle costumes that's like your
drindle I think you know it's kind of
like the authentic German outfits
guys have a little cultural moment okay
so yeah wear the best one and you'll get
a cash prize oh you guys you can't get
any better than that costumes beer pizza
pretzels Vibes um how can people get
reservations or what should they do are
available online at Carlos
islandcasino.com you can see it's that
Cheers Cheers
Island family business and football